[موسيقى]
مع تطلعات كبيرة من خلال الرغبة في
إنشاء تجربة زائر منقطعة النظير
في عام 2017 ، سافر فريق Expo 2020
مسافة 14000 كيلومتر إلى
نيوزيلندا ، وكان حجم جناح التنقل بالنسبة
لنا مهمًا إلى حد ما في الحقيقة ليس
منذ رحلة آه سبع سنوات ونصف
في  سيد الحلقات
حيث اعتنينا بخمسة
أقسام مختلفة ، تعاملنا مع شيء من
هذا النطاق المماثل ولكن في نصف
المدة الزمنية
لشهور ، شرع ريتشارد تايلور
وفريقه في تصميم تكريم ضخم
للرحلة الملحمية للتنقل البشري
أنشأنا ثلاثة  أكبر بثماني مرات من
العمالقة بالحجم الطبيعي إذا
وقفوا ، فسيبلغ ارتفاعهم حوالي 16 مترًا.
ملاحًا ورسام خرائط
، لم يكن إنشاء هذه النسخ المتماثلة شديدة الواقعية
مهمة سهلة ،
فقط في ملابسهم وحدها هناك
كيلومتر ونصف من القماش في كل منها
قطعة من
الملابس تلبسهم بالرافعات الشوكية والرافعات
20000 ثقب فردي تم حفرها في
الوجه لإدخال اللحى
وطباعة العيون ثلاثية الأبعاد
حتى لا يتم عملهم بمجرد إنشاء
عمالقة انطلق الفريق لعرض
تاريخ التنقل عبر القرون من
خلال  نوع من الفن يُدعى
إغاثة الجهير يبلغ طوله 53 مترًا ، وهو يحتوي
على أكثر من 200 شخصية بشرية ، و 100 حيوان
وأكثر من 100 مركبة تحكي
قصة التنقل من أشخاص خرجوا
من بدايات العالم ثم
إيجاد القدرة على الحركة من خلال تشكيل القبائل التي
تخترع الأحذية و  ثم بالطبع
إلى تنقل المركبات
والسفن والطائرات
الآن في موطنها الأخير في إكسبو 2020
، يقال إن العروض تبهر الزائرين من خلال
الإشادة بالكيفية التي كان التنقل بها
القوة الدافعة وراء
التنمية البشرية eleni jaakos cnn expo 2020 Dubai